au 21ème siècle la gaufre est toujours
eu mais de fait que l'on trouve dans
toutes les kermesses foire et braderies
en europe
elle est aussi l'un des éléments du
petit déjeuner en amérique du nord
sa popularité est même grandissante les
adeptes de la diète cétogène nous en
propose des centaines de versions sur
internet et le check-in wafo est
maintenant bien implanté dans les
restaurants québécois
non ce pas que belge sa partie de ce
qu'on appelle de manière très très
génériques sont au sud la combinaison de
la gauche traditionnelle belge et du
poulet frit du sud des états unis trouve
ses origines dans les plantations de
coton du début du 19e siècle
à gauche un peu épaisses créé legends
forme de pain en dire un très rapidement
intégré dans cette cuisine de pause que
la cuisine sol de la cuisine et des
noirs mais là le haut fait partie de ces
variations sur l'idée du pain avec la
viande aussi le matin sur le support
c'est pour une grande invention de
penser que du pain et de la viande ça
vous donner de l'énergie de la journée
le mariage de la gaufre et du poulet
frit peut surprendre mais il n'est ni
nouveau ni inusité on le trouve au menu
brunch d'une trentaine d'établissements
de montréal
les rôtisseries st-hubert l'ont même mis
à leur menu brunch du week end
pour moi c'est un peu a tellement festif
c'est un peu contradictoire dans un sens
le scris arrive à bien sans mais la
gauche et poulet frit tout en plus de 6
puis on voyait que le mouvement avec l
intendant si on y poulet on est 5 bat
donc pour nous ça faisait dix ans et
allié des libéraux dans verdun chez
jeanine café brunch on sert une gaufre
de poulet frit réinventé par le chef est
le propriétaire
ça nous pousse vers l'est souvent que
vous vous attabler à votre barre
j'imagine
je me fais plaisir ça arrive normalement
merci ça c'est le fameux plat la wii
nous on essaie de servir avec un lloris
a donné une touche exotique lagon twingo
ii mais pas trop sucré le poulet et
saumur est d'abord et ensuite pas nés ou
flocons de maïs et une purée de mangue
et miel infusé au gingembre
mais la vérité c'est que tout le monde à
la fin merci avant l'ouverture lorsqu'il
venu le moment de confectionner le menu
du restaurant la gaufre au poulet a été
un des premiers plats à être choisi et
puis on s'est pas trompé les gens en
redemandent
ça ça arrive qu'elles étaient des gens
qui connaissent pas cette combinaison la
de gonfler poulet frit donc un peu
sceptique au début mai
une fois qu'on laisse l ajout de 1 99%
des gens l'adorent ce sont les jazzman
d'harlem qu'ils ont vraiment adoptés et
popularisé dans les années 20 30 au
moment de la relève renaissance c'est là
que commence ses restos qui reste ouvert
très tard qu'ils ont fréquenté
essentiellement par des jazzmen et un
resto particulièrement qui s'appelait
world soccer crabe à la fin de la soirée
ils essaient de passer ces reste de la
journée et il part comme préparer le
déjeuner aussi bon ça tombe bien pour
les gens qui ont joué toute la soirée
ils ont besoin de quelque chose de boer
hâtif et qui hésite en savoir s'ils vont
souper ou s'ils vont ou déjà prendre le
déjeuner donc ils prennent ce bloc est
un peu improvisé comme ça et les
populations savent bien que le jazz est
donc c'est là qu'ils vont commencer à
manger ce truc extrêmement bourratif
[Musique]
quand on regarde l'histoire du jazz est
ce qu'on en parle de sept chinois serait
intéressé parce que je savais qu'il y
avait déjà des morceaux qui est évoqué
des plats particulier du de la soul
cuisine du sol faut il ya un morceau de
1935 d'europe et istres est impopulaire
xv boni bergen et qui a enregistré donc
en 1935 chinois faute donc le pl a été
immortalisée dans le répertoire jazz
qu'est ce qu'il vous plaît vous
personnellement à ce plan là le sucré
salé
j'aime ça
on a rajouté un peu de purée de mangue
ça c'est pour moi parce que dans cette
branche
ça prend un peu secret est un peu salée
et puis un petit peu de fruits quand
même on effectivement une vraie golf
belge c'est vraiment croustillants et
moelleux à l'intérieur
excessif on à la poitrine de
croustillant qui nous barrent donc on
est vraiment ce petit clin d'oeil lol
avec l'authenticité du chèque une loi
folle habituellement qui est vraiment
fait justement de babar accompagné que
touche québécoise de sirop d'érable pour
une petite pomme de terre avec notre
passé zone mans vécu ou qui veut par
dessus
est-ce que vous avez déjà mangé je les
ai essayé une fois dans un petit café du
mile end qu'il sert depuis quelques
années les jeunes s'adonnent avec trois
gros morceaux de poitrine de poulet pané
et une gaufre assez épaisse avec
beaucoup de avec beaucoup de sirop ils
ont qu'à ranger la moitié se passer
maintenant pour regarder pour plus pour
la fin alors ça c'est le sucré salé
[Musique]
[Rires]